the earth is full appoint six billion
years old but a human lifetime often
lasts for less than 100 years so why
care about the history of our planet
when the distant past seems so
inconsequential to everyday life you see
as far as we can tell earth is the only
planet in our solar system known to have
sparked life and the only system able to
provide life support for human beings
so why earth we know earth is unique for
having plate tectonics liquid water on
its surface and an oxygen-rich
atmosphere but this has not always been
the case and we know this because
ancient rocks have recorded the pivotal
moments in Earth's planetary evolution
and one of the best places to observe
those ancient rocks is in the Pilbara of
Western Australia the rocks here are 3.5
billion years old and they contain some
of the oldest evidence for life on the
planet
now often when we think of early life we
might imagine a Stegosaurus or maybe a
fish crawling onto land but the early
life that I'm talking about is simple
microscopic life like bacteria and their
fossils are often preserved as layered
rock structures called stromatolites
this simple form of life is almost all
we see in the fossil record for the
first 3 billion years of life on earth
our species can only be traced back in
the fossil record to a few hundred
thousand years ago we know from the
fossil record bacterial life had grabbed
a strong foothold by about 3.5 to 4
billion years ago but rocks older than
this have been neither the destroyed or
highly deformed through plate tectonics
so what remains a missing piece of the
puzzle is exactly when and how life on
earth began so here again is that
ancient volcanic landscape in the
Pilbara little did I know that our
research here would provide another clue
to that origin of Lash puzzle it was on
my first field trip here toward the end
of a full long week mapping project that
I came across something rather special
now it probably looks like a bunch of
wrinkly old rocks are actually
stromatolites and at the center of this
mound was a small peculiar rock about
the size of a child's hand it took six
months before we inspected this rock
under a microscope where one of my
mentors at the time Malcolm Walter
suggested the rock resembled guys all
right guys right is a rock type that
only forms in and around the edges of
hot spring pools now in order for you to
understand the significance of guys
right I need to take you back a couple
of centuries in 1871 in a letter to his
friend Joseph Hooker Charles Darwin
suggested what if life started in some
warm little pond with all sorts of
chemicals still ready to undergo more
complex changes well we know a form
little ponds we call them Hot Springs in
these environments you have hot water
dissolving minerals from the underlying
rocks this solution mixes with organic
compounds and results in a kind of
chemical factory which researchers have
shown can manufacture simple cellular
structures that are the first steps
toward life but a hundred years after
Darwin's letter deep sea hydrothermal
vents or hot vents were discovered in
the ocean and these are also chemical
factories this one is located along the
Tonga volcanic arc eleven hundred metres
below
sea level in the Pacific Ocean the black
smoke that you see billowing out of
these chimney like structures is also
mineral-rich fluid which is being fed
off by bacteria and since the discovery
of these deep-sea vents the favored
scenario for an origin of life has been
in the ocean and this is for good reason
deep-sea vents are well known in the
ancient rock record and it's thought
that the early Earth had a global ocean
and very little land surface so the
probability that deep sea vents were
abundant on the very early earth fits
well with an origin of life in the ocean
however our research in the Pilbara
provides and supports an alternative
perspective after three years finally we
were able to show that in fact our
little rock was guys right so this
conclusion suggested not only did hot
springs exists in our 3.5 billion year
old volcano in the Pilbara but it pushed
back evidence for life living on land in
hot springs in the geological record of
Earth by 3 billion years and so from a
geological perspective Darwin's warm
little pond is a reasonable origin of
life candidate of course it's still
debatable how life began on earth and it
probably always will be but it is clear
that it's flourished it is diversified
and it has become ever more complex
eventually it reached the age of the
human a species that has begun to
question its own existence and the
existence of life elsewhere is there a
cosmic community waiting to connect with
us or are we all there is a clue to this
puzzle again comes from the ancient rock
record at about 2.5 billion years ago
there
evidence that bacteria have begun to
produce oxygen kind of like plants do
today
geologists refer to the period that
followed as the great oxidation event it
is implied from rocks called banded iron
formations many of which can be observed
as hundreds of meter thick packages of
rock which are exposed in gorges that
carved their way through the karijini
national park in western australia the
arrival of free oxygen allowed two major
changes to occur on our planet first it
allowed complex life to evolve you see
life needs oxygen to get big and complex
and it produced the ozone layer which
protects modern life from the harmful
effects of the sun's UVB radiation so in
an ironic twist microbial life made way
for complex life and in essence
relinquished its three billion year
reign over the planet today we humans
dig up fossilized complex life and burn
it for fuel this practice pumps vast
amounts of carbon dioxide into the
atmosphere and like our microbial
predecessors we have begun to make
substantial changes to our planet and
the effects of those are encompassed by
global warming
unfortunately the ironic twist here
could see the demise of humanity and so
maybe the reason we aren't connecting
with life elsewhere intelligent life
elsewhere is that once it evolves
extinguishes itself quickly if the rocks
could talk I suspect they might say this
life on Earth is precious it is the
product of four or so billion years of a
delicate and complex coevolution between
life and earth of which humans only
represent the very last speck of time
you can use this information as a guide
or fall
cost or an explanation as to why it
seems so lonely in this part of the
galaxy but use it to gain some
perspective about the legacy that you
want to leave behind on the planet that
you call home
[Applause]
[Music]